[Music]
on today's show we talk about some hard
hard stuff so watch out for the little
ears in the room we talk about putting
down a beloved dog and how we tell our
kids we talk about seasonal affective
disorder
we also talk about how to talk to your
teenage daughter when you find out dad
is not a good guy stay tuned
[Music]
[Applause]
hey what's up
this is john with the dr john deloney's
show still putting my headphones in
james is in a hurry today
not really and before we even started
james said no banter so i'm going to try
not to banter
before we started you said let's go and
that's when i started
i literally said all right let's get
going james and then i promptly blamed
it on you
ugh i think we need to call in the show
together
and talk to ourselves about how we treat
one another and by we i mean how i treat
you i'm sorry james i forgive you this
happened i've been on the road a lot
like running and gunning and that
sounded so stupid yeah i'm just ruining
gun and bro like i'm wearing a football
jersey right now i'm an idiot
so but i've been going all over the
place and
we got a major problem
here's the problem
people listen to the show
way more than i thought
and here's
that's problem number one
lots of people know things about my kids
it's just hard to be lulled in like you
and i are just having a chit chat me and
you and kelly sarah
they're listening to this thing they
know things about my family and that's
super weird mainly because i tell them
so it's not like they're creeping but
then
they are going in doing some of this
and i was psychologically unprepared for
that
i know i get like that's the whole point
of this show i'm gonna say how is this a
problem this is it's not a problem it's
just
whoa
we can no longer say there's 18 of us
the gang has expanded there's at least
40
maybe 40. it's sobering for sure
you have something you need to tell us
james
no
good folks james is james is working on
some personal issues
not really he's just very handsome all
right let's go to dan in
chi-town
chicago hey dan what's up man
hey dr john how are you doing today we
are partying all all day and all morning
it's like super early in the morning so
we haven't been partying very long and
by partying
i had like a cup of regular coffee in my
decaf that's how we're kind of getting
the wheels off here this morning how are
you man all right sounds good good um
listen first of all i just want to say
thanks to you and your team for help
making this past year a lot more
manageable for me and probably a lot of
other people who haven't gotten a chance
to thank you so dude you're awesome
brother thank you hey is it cool
for people who aren't in chicago just
call it chai town that feels like some
insider lingo
no that's fine i got no problem with it
personally all right good i i knew one
thing growing up in texas and that you
don't fight chicago ends because they'll
kill you so that's awesome i don't wanna
i don't wanna i don't wanna cross his
dreams brother dan
no you're good man all right so what's
up brother how can i help
all right so i got a question that i
thought you might enjoy discussing today
and that's about seasonal affective
disorder oh man it's the worst
[Music]
do you have it
uh so i'll tell you my story kind of
what i've been dealing with this week
and maybe you can kind of shed some
light on it
all right so um you know it's kind of
mid-september up here in chicago over
the past week i really have not felt
like myself i've been more exhausted
um you know just unable to focus i feel
forgetful
it's kind of like you know how you
sometimes they say you're driving from a
to b and you don't know how you get
there right right and um so i just been
foggy i haven't really been sick or had
any other symptoms that was a worry i
haven't changed my kind of daily routine
i haven't been any more active i've
actually had to i just stopped going to
softball this week because i've been so
tired and i've had to nap several days
after work which just is not the usual
for me
so i was talking with some friends at
work and some of them felt similar and
one of them said her husband deals with
a seasonal affective disorder and
the only way i know about is my mom has
dealt with it for years so
um i wonder maybe that's what i'm
feeling i know you got a wide audience
and maybe some others
may not be familiar with this
but i was just wondering if you could
speak to this condition who is at risk
what do we know about it how can we kind
of manage it the best that we can
wow dude well thanks for the call man
that's a great question and
i got
so
i'll answer your question with um one of
my own personal experiences so i grew up
i mean i moved to nashville from west
texas which is about 30 to 45 minutes
from
the other time another time zone
and then i moved to nashville which is
about 30 45 minutes maybe an hour to the
eastern time zone
what that meant was in where i'm coming
from in west texas
it stayed light till eight or nine
o'clock every night
then we got to nashville and it was
getting dark and this is in the late
fall
winter it's getting dry at 4 30 in the
afternoon i'd go outside and be pitch
black
and it was about february
that i didn't want to move and i'd never
experienced this and i started thinking
it's my job my marriage my wife is me my
kid
and then i realized this is the longest
i've ever gone in my entire life since i
was zero without sunshine without steady
amounts of sun and a rhythm and being
outside and then all of a sudden i was
eating garbage and i wasn't sleeping and
and i wasn't exercising stuff
so yeah man it was big time and so i had
to take some pretty
um direct measures to work through that
um it does surprise me that we're
a few
weeks
into the fall i mean i don't even think
we're technically in the fall yet do you
have other stuff going on stress do you
have other relational stuff going on
something no something doesn't sound
right maybe it is
um not that i can think of uh you know
it's it is starting to kind of get dark
here before seven
seven o'clock at you know at nighttime
so okay um nothing i can think of
offhand nothing i can put my finger on
that i've been doing any different like
i said
um
you know so i can't i can't figure
anything else out that what that might
be causing this but i'm telling you i
got outside i got more sunlight this
weekend and i snapped back like in an
instant oh that's awesome all right so
here to answer some of the
criteria and it's been a minute since
i've dug into this but
um seasonal affective disorder
one i just want we love calling things
disorders and we love
giving people diagnostics and labels and
saying oh you're
you have a thing
really
we
well i look at seasonal defective
disorder it affects millions and
millions of people right and if you want
to meet the criteria it's a couple of
years of experience major depressive
disorder
uh and it's it's got to be focused on
these particular
um times of year late fall
winter when there is no sunshine there's
a compressed sunlight and people are
stuck indoors which then has derivative
things like we talked about you're not
eating very well you're just laying
around you're probably watching a lot of
screens you're not out connecting with
other humans you're not getting sunshine
you're not exercising and an am so it
does affect millions of people i don't
like this as a diagnostic i like to take
into account we have some natural
rhythms that our bodies have been
been working with with nature for
thousands and thousands or millions of
years
and then about a hundred years ago we
developed
work schedules and light bulbs and so if
you think about it if we were all
farmers if we'd all been hunter
gatherers this is just part of the time
we just kind of shut down and things
slow down for us
now that shutdown and that slow down we
call depression and say that we're
broken and say that we got to keep
charging hard right in february right so
i don't like to look at as much as my
body's broken as much as just a good
signal like you did dude i need to get
outside and get some stuff there is some
get some sunlight get some movement
there is some geographical um
implications here i didn't experience
this in texas ever i've got several
friends who grew up with me in texas
arizona they moved up north
and it just that grayness that low sky
that the winter months just lays on
people right
and it's marked by hopelessness
frustration you know decreased physical
activity and all that you mentioned a
couple of things that i think is just
important to call out
one you quit playing softball and so
there's the physical movement part but
there's also the buddies part and
they're just talking trash and hollering
at your friends and laughing and getting
angry and suddenly sprinting all those
things have
major physiological consequences
and
just the
so what did you do this weekend that was
different
uh well i really enjoy being outdoors
and kind of working around the yard and
around my house so uh just getting out
and
being outside i mean
like like this the past week
i i had zero energy to even do anything
after work like i said i had to come
home and nap and
you know just couldn't do anything and
then i kind of was a little bit more
intentional like you said i i i'm like
you and that i don't like to compromise
in my sleep
that is kind of the first thing i i
always try to get back to and i felt a
lot better after
catching up on sleep and getting outside
and doing things that that bring me a
lot of joy good for you man all right so
there may be
a lot of this in my head and this is the
best i can read i'm not a
chemist and i'm not a
vitamin d researcher but i think a lot
of this is related to vitamin d and what
it does to hormones and
neurotransmitters melatonin serotonin
melatonin serotonin all that stuff
modulates immune function all those
things
um
here's what i really want to challenge
folks like you and me to do
it's easy when
we have a week or two or maybe even
three we want to nap
we just want to rest
and what i want to challenge us to do is
listen to our bodies in those seasons
and pay attention
meaning and probably the best thing for
you this past week was just to lay low
something about your body was telling
you hey man let's just dial it back a
bit
let's just rest you need you need to get
some extra sleep some extra you time
just chill and i just said you time like
me and you were knitting a pillow right
now we need some you time that's
ridiculous but like your body was just
letting you know and then
your mind came back online a little bit
after some rest and said
hey man this can't become a pattern this
isn't the way we're gonna live
we took a nap right we we took a break
for a week and now we've gotta come back
online i gotta get outside i gotta go
move my body i gotta reach out and call
people
so
the last thing i want people doing is
feeling low for a week or two or three
and then announcing to themselves in the
world i've got a disorder
no man
you need some sunlight you need some
human connection you need to turn the
screens off you need to write something
you need to be okay when your body
downshifts a little bit in the middle of
the winter and in chicago you guys don't
screw around with winter last time i was
there was like minus a thousand degrees
it made me
i've heard all my life that hell is hot
and after spending a few days in chicago
in february
i don't know man i don't know i think
latin for hot maybe chicago real cold
it's really cold
anyway
um if you find yourself if you can look
back on your calendar and you just think
i am
not doing okay i am unseasonably low
i want you to go outside and move your
body even when it's great especially in
the morning it's a big this this morning
i got three and a half hours of sleep
last night i flew in
i flew in
um got on a plane yesterday flew right
back in after being in another state
landed and drove straight to an event
that lasted late into the night and then
i have two keynotes to give today it was
a late night i got three hours of sleep
last night sounds like you're running a
gun in
well played jimmy well played
running gunning cause
because i'm patrick mahomes and i want
to be in the football leagues the
national football leagues is that what
they call nfls
um act like i don't know what the nfl is
i know the nfl is but
the first thing i did this morning is i
did have to keep on working on my stuff
on my talks this morning but i went
outside and i got sunlight even when
it's gray got sunlight got to move your
body
even when it's cold go outside bundle up
if at all possible
exercise is an antidepressant make sure
you move your body make sure your
intention about calling people even if
it's to say hey i'm not doing so great
can we come hang out even if we're gonna
go hang out and go for a walk in the
gray do it do it do it
lots of bright light right when you wake
up my wife makes fun of me in the winter
because i it it looks like a stadium
inside our house
especially where i'm working turn all
the lights on right when i wake up
and
if it lasts for more than a couple of
weeks call somebody
let somebody that you're not doing okay
let somebody know that you're not doing
okay
um
it can be real heavy and if you are
leaning towards a depressive season
man
just spending some time in the gray by
yourself and the cold can
sometimes push us over the edge
if you ever have thoughts of hurting
yourself call somebody
if you ever have thoughts that i'm not
okay call somebody
okay
dan thank you so much man we haven't
talked about seasonal defective
affective disorder we haven't talked
about the grays as i call them
or the
the bends i guess the bends is a a great
radiohead album and two has to do with
diving but i just call it the bends i
just feel bent over but i just feel low
right bent low in the season but dan
thanks for the call brother and get some
sunshine or how about not live in
chicago that could be another thing all
right hey we'll be right back on the dr
john delonay show
[Music]
hey what's up this is john let's talk
about a good night's sleep
it's important for your physical health
your mental health your sanity you name
it if you're not sleeping good the first
question i want you to ask yourself is
do i need a new mattress and here's how
you tell if you're tossing and turning
all night because you can't get
comfortable if you woke up at night and
you're all hot
right or if in the morning your back
hurts if you have any of these issues
you may need to check out a new mattress
if you're ready for a new mattress i
want you to check out dream cloud it's
the mattress i own and you'll love it
and they're currently running their
biggest offer ever 400 bucks in
accessories plus an additional 250
discount only for deloney listeners
that's a total of about 650 dollars in
accessories and savings visit
dreamcloudsleep.com
dreamcloudsleep.com and enter promo code
deloney to get a new mattress today and
enjoy 650 bucks in savings that's
dreamcloudsleep.com promo code
d-e-l-o-n-y good night
and we're back
let's go to that was ridiculous
hey you think if this doesn't work out i
could be a metal singer james
yeah yeah you could
there's not a high bar there
uh brian he works security out in the
lobby he's just shaking his head like
i've really trained my whole life and
this is where i have to work i've done
something tragically wrong let's go to
sarah in cincinnati ohio
i don't know where that accident's from
but we're going to go with it what's up
sarah
hi how are you john how are you so good
how are you
i say so good it's great i've got coffee
i work in the air conditioning and we're
doing okay how about you
good i'm doing fine doing fine so what's
up
i'm calling because one of our dogs
was recently diagnosed with cancer
and i'm wondering how to best handle it
with my young kids oh great question how
old are your kids
well in particular my son he's four and
a half he'll be five in february so my
daughter's two so she's not
real not my biggest concern it's more
him that i'm concerned with
wow
tell me about this dog
oh he's the best
we we've had him he's 10 and a half
he's a pity boxer mix and he's just
super sweet and
loving and
[Music]
he's honestly like the best dog we could
have ever gotten so that's so great and
was it just a ride or die through the
through the birth of your kids
too oh yeah
yeah he he was he's been a protector and
he cuddles them and loves them and
kisses them and
loves them so
so we deal with a lot of hard stuff on
this show
this may be the closest i get to tearing
up okay so i'm going to work hard
because i love dogs i think they
yeah i think they're pretty remarkable
um
so here's
i'll just jump right into this can i
tell you a story about myself yeah
yeah um i had a
beloved dog
and
in fact
i used to tell my wife this dog was in
my bed long before you were so let's
just get priority straight right uh that
dog um she was an old bastard hound she
smelled so bad
um shared a pillow with me i mean it's
obnoxious but that dog was lit he was
incredible
and when i moved that dog moved with me
that dog was ride or die disgusting and
gross all the things you would think a
21 year old
guy just you walk into their apartment
like what is this it was that uh but i
love that dog and then we got another um
basset down named baxter and that dog
was rad too
molly passed away before molly died
before we had kids
and baxter was still around when i had
hank
and um that's right when i was learning
all about trauma and how it works and
what is the best way to navigate some of
this especially with little kids
so i'll tell you about something that
happened um
got news that um
baxter
was not gonna make it
and
we sit very similar and so i called a
buddy
and we were going out to to his ranch
that day just to the kids to run around
and i was at the
veterinarian's office and i'd taken the
dog in and we're gonna put the dog down
and something felt weird and so i called
him
and said hey would it be weird if i
you know we i'm gonna be i'm with the
vet now we're gonna put the dog down and
then i brought the dog out to the ranch
we buried him there
and says that weird i know there's kids
running around and he's a rancher he's
very very very wise
and he said something that stuck in my
soul
he got quiet and said if you don't take
this opportunity
to teach your son
about death
you failed them
and i thought well hey that's a little
bit harsh
that's just how ranchers talk to each
other right
um and so i got out to
the ranch um
we put the dog down
and i held the dog through the whole
thing and i think that's really
important by the way is that you hold
that dog through that season
my kid was not there for that moment
okay that was a lot
um
but
when i got out to the ranch my buddy had
set out one big shovel for me and one
little shovel for my son
and
we
both
dug the grave together
and there's a physical component to
grief
we
prayed for that dog
and we talked about the fun and the joy
that the dog had brought us
the tender moments the hugs the things
that we were going to miss
and my son watched me tear up
and then i watched i had to answer some
hard questions like daddy we can put the
dirt on top
and as he was processing
oh this is it
this
this is it there's a finality to it
and my buddy in the distance it's it's
my single most prized possession outside
of humans
took a photo and it's of a couple
hundred yards away of me and my son
digging that grave together and i'll
keep that as long as i live it was an
important moment for me as a dad and as
somebody who teaches about grief and who
walks through
hard stuff with people
so what i would tell you is
the last great gift this dog will give
to you
is to
have a create a touchstone moment for
you
and your son especially but even your
two and a half year old
that
will will ride through the next five 10
15 years of y'all's life
because here's what happened in our home
just a few years later that my granddad
passed away
and i was able to point back to hey
remember when
and then my grandmother passed away hey
remember when
and so baxter's legacy through our
family has been significant
and it was hard
and it was absolutely right
and good
and so what i would tell you is as my
friend rachel cruz says share don't
scare so be honest you don't have to be
um
overly detailed and
i don't think a four-year-old should be
in there when they give your dog a shot
or anything like that
i do think if at all possible if y'all
can
bury your dog together i think that's
really important i think that's a neat
moment and it'll be heavy it'll be hard
and there will be tears and there'll be
hugs
and there'll be lots of hard hard
questions i probably wouldn't have my
two and a half year old out there just
because there's some
there's some gaps there developmentally
but i would tell them that the dog's
really really sick and dog is going to
die and it's not going to be here
anymore
and then when she asks questions it's a
matter of fact stuff it's bending down
and looking your two-year-old in the eye
and saying
remember
remember he died he's not here anymore
and we really miss him and then she may
say i really miss him too
and
it's good for her to see mom miss
so what's this dog's name
jack jack jack jack
yeah tell me one awesome thing about
jack jack
oh man
he's he's like your basset he he's a
mama's boy he lays on my pillow he
he is i guarantee you jack smells better
than my than molly did
for sure
[Laughter]
can i ask you would you
tell him ahead of time that it's
happening or would you wait until
um
uh
i think that's up to you guys i think
that's okay i don't think there's a
right way or wrong way to do that um i
would probably
um
let him know that i have to take the dog
to the to the dog doctor to the
veterinarian's office because uh he's
very very sick
okay and then when we go there we can
let him know that he died he died there
um and then
again asking hard questions we gave him
a shot to make him feel better because
he was hurting so much
and he goes to sleep and gently
dies and be direct with your language
not evasive not passed away that doesn't
mean anything to a four year old
um letting making sure you say the words
jack jack died
right and um
it was it was
um it was jack jack's time jack jack was
sick very very sick and his body got
tired
and um i would avoid he didn't feel good
so we gave him a shot i think a
four-year-old might internalize the next
time he gets a cough like he's gonna be
hiding under his bed or something from
mom
right um
but
let l give him the gift of
learning the hard realities of life and
that people we love and things we love
and pets we love pass away they die
and that mom's gonna be there and walk
alongside us through this whole
situation
so sarah i know this is a show about
people
but my heart's broken for you guys i'm
glad that you had to had that experience
with jack jack hey can i tell you this
one more thing
yes it's a strange thing about dogs
and i'm intentionally not talking about
cats cause i think cats are evil i think
they're the worst animal ever created
and i know there's a few cat listeners
of this show so
send me your mean tweets i don't even
know how twitter works so tweet away but
dogs
man
cats maybe two but they live that eight
to 12 year
time period
and they tend to mark decades for us
right
it tends to be the during college and
then the first job or
when i met my
significant other through the dating and
then the first couple of hard years of
trying to figure out how we're going to
be married together
or couldn't have kids and then tried and
then had kids in the first couple of
years they get so they mark seasons
and often when our dog passes away it's
as though it's it's a page turn in our
home just because of that decade time
does that make sense
so you're gonna miss jack jack and
you're gonna have this heavy realization
that you're in a new season of life
does that make sense honor that for
yourself
because it's real and it's heavy it's
hard
yeah
and
are you married
yes yes and you got two little ones
two little ones yeah there's a very real
reality that will set in that
this is the new world
there's no going back
it's not just you and your husband and
jack jack going on hikes or staying up
too late or jack being like hey what's
going on back there right all that's
over now you got two little kids and so
you're in that season now and there's
something about grieving man there's the
end of party time and now i'm just mom
with two kids and husband and now we get
to recreate some new adventure going
forward
but it just said i don't know there's
something about that decade time period
it just tends to be snapshots and i've
just
been so fortunate to
have some ride or die old dogs that have
been with me in these just snapshot
seasons
and i don't know i just think dogs are
amazing so good for you sarah for giving
jack jack the
mama who loved him
glad he protected you from knucklehead
husband and brought you through with two
little ones what a magical magical
journey
and uh
high five to you in the new season build
something great we'll be right back on
the dr john daloni show
one of the most common questions folks
ask me is what they should do when
anxiety or panic strikes like a
lightning bolt i've been helping folks
101 for years but i wanted to create
something that everyone could use
anywhere at any time so i created a free
guided meditation it's not really a
meditation but really me just walking
with you through your anxiety alarms
from start to finish i'll guide you
through a breathing exercise and show
you how to lean in listen and head
towards healing it is free and it's for
everyone you can download this guided
meditation today for free at
johndaloni.com
all right what up gang we're back let's
go to lynn in philadelphia we're born
and raised
in
playgrounds john most of my days what's
up
hi dr john thanks so much for taking my
call of course thanks for calling how
are you this morning
i'm okay um i have a question i'm hoping
i can get some guidance and advice from
you i will do the best i can and if i
answer it terribly we're just going to
edit it out and no one will even know
this call happened which is so good so
right now only you and your friends will
be like i call that guy he's an idiot
so what's up
so my question is how to parent through
my 15 year old daughter
expressing a desire to reach out to her
birth father who is my ex-husband who is
not a safe person and has not been in
her life or mine since she's been
born hmm
yikes
so
when you say not a safe person let's
start there that's a big one
yeah so um
so obviously from my perspective as uh
married to him there was repeated
unfaithfulness
verbal emotional abuse but beyond that
there was also a sustained pornography
addiction throughout our marriage that i
found out during the marriage and then
that escalated to
pornography with kids or at least with
pre-teen girls
looking at porn yeah
i found when we were
he's not
what happened when that came to light
that he was into child pornography
so i mean remember this is almost 20
years ago i was in my early 20s i found
it on the computer
and i didn't understand at that point
like oh i need to call the police i
understand that now
i didn't i instead got in touch with
um you know a counselor or a therapist
through church and he did go a little
bit but it didn't really
seem to help and he wasn't invested in
that
and so in my mind um naively i kind of
lumped all of that evilness together
as just oh this is more of his
pornography addiction i know now
like i'm a licensed foster parent i'm
trauma informed i understand that that
is a reportable offense but like since
it's so long ago
and it was like on a home computer that
no longer exists like i haven't reported
anything
about him and i haven't been in touch
with him in like 15 years
so before the day is over
you gotta make a report
okay
you have to do that
okay
um the
yeah you have to
for
the kids caught up in that stuff
for
um
yeah he got to
okay
yeah you got to make that call today um
and you can let them know i know this is
20 years ago
i
know that 20 years ago i should have
made this call
um and i didn't and here we are and so i
need to report this
and i would also be honest and say i
also know that i've got a 15 year old
daughter who's asking questions about
her dad and this looks bad
yeah
and oh you're going to get me all riled
up man um i know no
the
so
even if
i give you grace for 20 years ago you're
in the middle of a storm and you're in a
mess and this is all lumped into a big
pot
the fact that y'all took this to a
church building and they sat on it makes
me insane
right and to be honest i don't know i
mean i wasn't part of those uh
counseling sessions i don't know how
much was shared
other than you know i'm a you know he
was addicted to porn i don't know if he
went into what type or
anything like that again like in my head
at the time it was all
kind of a blur like we got divorced when
i was pregnant with my now 15 year old
daughter so i was just
a mess
understand he was seeing an 18 year old
at the time that i found out when i was
a few months pregnant and then i found
pornography and it was just all a big
blur
um for me right
um but yeah
but i i hear you and i get it make that
call now i i know in a number of states
they've passed there is no statute of
limitations on that okay and
in fact
in a couple of states where i've got
connections it's a crime to not
okay
not report it okay well this we were in
tennessee at the time
yeah wherever it happens to be um
it's a crime to not report it
and i think in texas they just said if
you know about it and don't report it
you will be fired from whatever job you
are happen to be working
for
and you're subject to criminal stuff so
it's okay yeah make the call
um even if they raid his computer and
there's nothing on it and he's a changed
person
the the the downside to that is he has
an inconvenient day
uh or he's subject to an investigation
that finds that nothing's going on
otherwise
we're going to protect some children
right okay yep um
when it comes to your daughter what's
what's her
does he even want to talk to her is he
responding back to her what's the deal
here
or she just had to she just has
questions
she has questions right so i saw in her
browsing history she was looking him up
researching him
you know um throughout her life if ever
she's asked questions i've answered but
i haven't given more information than
needed
but now that she's older
we we talked about it pretty recently
and i was she wanted all the details so
i was pretty upfront with her including
um about the pornography and so forth um
and so after all that a day or two later
out of the blue she said just so you
know at some point i want to reach out
to him of course and and so i just i you
know i tried to keep like don't freak
out face on and i just said well you
know well got it what are you hoping to
what are you hoping happens or what do
you
what are you hoping to accomplish type
of question and he she just said i have
questions yeah
absolutely and so i said okay got it and
so here's the big question
here's a big question
what was it about me
that you walked away from
right what was it about all those other
girls what was it about all the other
women what was it about the your
addictions what was it about your
depression your whatever
that was so much more important than me
i just need to know that and yeah
and so
on you gave her
that that curiosity that creativity that
desire to know herself and
you've been on trauma-informed journeys
you're learning you
you love and care for foster kids that
that who in my question is foundational
to all of us
so her desire to just know some stuff
uh is real and in her 15 year old brain
her desire to tell him what she thinks
is real too
that's in 45 year old brains i'm gonna
find him and i'm just gonna tell him
that
it never does anything but it feels like
it's gonna feel good
so all those questions are good
right now
the last contact you've had
is with a felon
and as the mother of a 15 year old you
must protect your daughter
right
and so it's okay to say your questions
are super legit
you ask me anything
but in the same way you would not let
her connect with a 35 or 45 year old
person on the sex offender registry list
she doesn't get contact in that that
level of boundary i don't care that it
happens to be her dad
okay and you can let her know in that
uncertain terms i have not spoken to
this man in 20 years and last i knew he
was very unsafe
i wouldn't let a strange child around
him i'm not going to let you
also one thing that she can do is write
letters to him that she doesn't mail she
doesn't have his address but she can
hang on to him
when you make this call have you not
spoken to him for two decades or 15
years um it's been about 13 years
because i did end up getting sole
custody a year or two into her life okay
and so that's when we last had contact
through child pornography didn't come up
during the their custody hearing
um we didn't really have it didn't no it
didn't go through a hearing like that he
basically said he was not going to visit
her and so his rights went down to he
can only contact her through writing
right now he's not allowed to visit her
or anything and it wasn't
he just said he he wasn't going to
and so we just said all through a
mediator yeah it was all through a
mediator we didn't go before a judge at
all okay for a hearing
i haven't heard of mediated parental
rights being terminated before but maybe
i don't i don't know about it his
parental yeah his rights aren't
terminated
so he's on paper he's still her father
but he can't he's not by law allowed to
visit her he's only allowed to
communicate with her in writing that's
where it was left when
like 13 years ago
and so i wanna i know he is your
ex-husband i know he's her dad
but i want you to listen to what you're
saying
and i want to challenge you that your
daughter needs you now
because on paper
he still has the ability to communicate
with her
and he's a sex offender
right
yep
i know that's so hard i know this brings
up every demon on earth in your soul
and i also know that you know these
things
how long has that been haunting you that
he's gonna reach out that has to have
been a ghost that's been chasing you for
15 years um
i've always been scared that she would
want to reach out to him not so much
that he would reach out to her
um think of think of her reaching out to
him as less about him and more about her
trying to find out who she is this is
this is an exploration to find herself
and it's got to go through him
right and that's and i get that and and
she's kind of going through the stage
where she's pushing against a lot of
boundaries
right right right i get it right so this
is another one and so i want to be
careful like
my fear is in setting a boundary of no
no communication no nothing that she's
just going to try to find a way around
it right she's easy enough to find
online 1000 she will
yeah and what would you do
if your daughter was doing what she
could to communicate
with somebody that you knew
was addicted to child pornography
what would you do
i'll tell you what you would do anything
you'd cut the wi-fi you'd throw every
computer in the dumpster
okay
yeah
you would go to
you would go to hell and back to keep
your daughter away from that guy that
guy just happens to be her dad
right
and that's why this stuff has to be
formalized you got to make a report
it's got to be written down
and you still got access to you still
have his social security number and his
stuff and all that and there's going to
be some shame on your part for not
reporting it expect that yeah 100
and at some point you're going to let
yourself you're going to have to forgive
yourself and go forward and not continue
to be anchored to i should have i should
have i should have in the past you
didn't so here we are
right
i would also
recommend
your daughter's gonna look for any way
this quest to figure out who she is is
it's universal we all go through it
she is going to
look for ways
that you are the bad guy here which
gives her permission to break your
boundaries
okay
so
there is a difference between saying
this man was sick
this man was an addict
this man got into some evil stuff and
there's a difference between that and i
hate this guy this guy's right
and so the best you can
keep it about facts and data and not
about your opinions
yes does that make sense and that way
yeah it will not it it will it's going
to turn that anyway you just don't like
him or you're just mad that he fill in
the blank that's expect that but that
way there's never that sliver of she's
holding out on me
right
this is yeah and i like definitely
yeah and i've certainly tried to never
ever
say he's bad he just sees that
she would ask me when she was younger if
he was bad and i said you know he's just
sad and he needs healing and he's made
bad choices but i never i try to never
villainize i think it's very fair to say
he's very very sick
and there will come a moment
when your daughter will look you in the
eye and say why didn't you call
and you're have to be honest with her
say i screwed that right
yep
i should've and i didn't i messed up and
that will never
ever
ever happen again
i hate this for you lynn i hate all of
it i hate it for those little girls
involved in the pornography stuff
i hate it for
your daughters had to grow up with a dad
who just cashed out
man
if you know and i'm telling everybody
now
if you know of somebody
who's involved in child pornography
call
today
period full stop end of story
conversation over call today
if you know somebody who's hurting kids
call today
if you know somebody who's neglecting
their kids call them today
those kids deserve better than that and
they need all of us
call today
man
and lynn you're gonna have to
take a big breath go do some hard stuff
you're gonna have to set that shame down
your daughter needs you daughter needs
you
let's protect our kids good folks let's
protect our kids
all right so as we wrap up today's show
oh man
it's been raining a lot in nashville
like crazy
and
shout out seasonal effectiveness
disorder
this snorter
that's i don't even know what a dis
snorter is i know what a disorder is
and so during one of the breaks james
producer extraordinaire ran in his
second favorite song of all time
we all know that bette midler's the rose
is his favorite song but this is number
two
this song's by the one and only rihanna
and it's umbrella
and it goes like this
uh-huh uh-huh yeah rihanna uh-huh uh-huh
good girl gone bad rut
uh uh uh-huh uh-huh take three action
uh-huh uh-huh
hov that's not the hov lane is it nope
jay-z
no clouds in my stones let it rain a
hydroplane in the bank coming down with
the dow jones when the clouds come we
gone we rock a fellow we fly higher than
weather and g5s are better you know me
you know me
in anticipation for precipitation
stacked chips for the rainy day
j-man
nope j rain man is back with little miss
sunshine rihanna where are you at
you have my heart and will never be
worlds apart
and that's when you need me there with
you i'll always share because
you can stand under my ella ella ella
james say it umbrella right here on the
dr john dolone's show
[Music]